Nível de vitamina B12 alta pode causar
problemas? O médico pediu para
suspender. Bem, depende. Se essa B12 tá
alta porque você tá tomando a
suplementação, geralmente isso não causa
grandes problemas, tá? É raro, mas eu
vou falar daqui a pouco quais seriam as
consequências. Agora, a saose tá alta no
seu sangue sem você tá repondo, isso
pode significar algumas doenças graves,
tá? Então vamos falar primeiro da
suplementação excessiva. Então quando
você usa doses muito altas de vitamina
B12 especialmente injetável, isso pode
aumentar os níveis de B12
temporariamente. Geralmente não é muito
tempo porque é uma vitamina
hidrossolúvel e o organismo consegue
eliminar, mas pode acontecer alguns
problemas que eu já vou falar. Então,
mas se você tem níveis persistentemente
altos de B12 sem suplementação, isso
pode indicar doença no fígado, doença no
rim, alguns tipos de câncer, como
leucemia, câncer de fígado, pulmão e
pâncreas, tá? Mas de novo, só se você
não tá repondo B12, a B12 tá alta, é que
você tem que investigar isso, OK? A
maioria das pessoas não tem sintoma
nenhum com excesso de vitamina B12,
porque ela é eliminada pela urina, né?
Ela é hidrossolúvel.
Porém, em casos raros de megadoses,
especialmente pessoas que estão
utilizando por muito tempo, pode
acontecer
de sintomas de acne, vemidão na pele,
dor de cabeça, náusea, diarreia,
tontura, palpitações, ansiedade,
insônia, formigamento em extremidades,
que é neuropatia periférica, reações
alérgicas raras, mas potencialmente
graves. Mas tudo isso que eu tô falando
é muito difícil acontecer. Eu na prática
não vejo isso acontecendo, tá? E pessoas
que têm insuficiência renal, que estão
com B12 muito alta, pode ter pior da
função renal. O que eu faço na prática
que a pessoa que tá com a vitamina B12
acima de 1500 no sangue, a gente
suspende a
suplementação ou reduz muito a dose da
suplementação e se a pessoa tiver essa
B2 alta naturalmente sem suplementação,
investiga a função renal do fígado,
investiga a questão de possibilidade de
doenças hematológicas e também de
possíveis cânceres. OK?
Existe estudos observacionais que
sugerem que níveis persistentemente
persistentemente altos de B12 podem
estar associados a maior risco de
mortalidade geral, especialmente em
idosos e hospitalizados. Só que a
relação causal não foi estabelecida.
Então, provavelmente é o é o caso da
pessoa que já tem a B12 alta de base e
não a
suplementação. Então, como tem essa
associação entre B12 persistentemente
alta e a maior incidência de alguns
tipos de câncer, seja câncer sólido como
neoplasia do sangue, né, mas isso não é
um efeito direto da vitamina, OK? Então,
o que fazer se a B2 alta? suspender a
suplementação, se for por causa da
suplementação ou reduzir a dose, e se
não for por conta de suplementação,
investigar causas secundárias. Como eu
falei, pode ser suficina renal,
hepática, ou pode ser algum tipo de
câncer, algum problema hematológico, OK?